بينما تقصف المدفعية الأوكرانية القوات الروسية، فإن
أحد أولئك الذين يستهدفون
قوات فلاديمير بوتين ويوجه النار
ليس جنديًا محترفًا فحسب، بل هو أيضًا أم
لثلاثة أطفال وعلامة النداء الخاصة بها nizlamna
غير القابلة للكسر، لقد
رأيت الكثير في هذه المرحلة لدرجة أنني
لا أستطيع ذلك  تقول: "تفاجأ بسهولة،
لكن بالطبع هناك خطر دائم،
الإسلام لديها ابنتان
وابن يبلغ من العمر خمس سنوات لم ترهم
منذ أبريل، هل الأمر
صعب؟ أنا أسأل، بالطبع يشعرون
بالإهانة عندما لا أكون كذلك".  هناك عندما
يحتاجون إلي كوالد لكنهم يفهمون أنه
يجب على شخص ما القيام بهذا العمل من أجل
بلداننا، كما يقول،
وغالبًا ما يكون هذا العمل مروعًا
لأولئك الموجودين في الخطوط الأمامية هنا في
الجنوب، وقد قدم لنا اللواء الميكانيكي 47
هذا الفيديو الذي يقولون إنه يظهر قدراتهم
القوات التي تتعرض للنيران الروسية
حتى أثناء جمع جثث
رفاقهم الذين سقطوا،
مركبات برادلي القتالية التي زودتها بها الولايات المتحدة والتي تحمل ندوب القتال الذي لا هوادة فيه،
هذه المركبة هي في الحقيقة رمز لمدى صعوبة
المعركة
هنا في الجنوب، يمكنك أن ترى أن هناك
الكثير من  الأضرار الناجمة عن النيران حيث
يقول الأوكرانيون إن السبب في ذلك هو أن هذه المركبة تعرضت
لضربات من المدفعية الروسية 152
ملم من قذائف المدفعية الروسية
ويقولون إن هذا ليس غريبًا.
تبدو معظم المركبات هكذا
وتقول القوات إنها تحرز تقدمًا
ولكن غالبًا ما تظل متورطة في
حقول الألغام الروسية و  وابل من
قذائف المدفعية يتذكر سائق برادلي الملقب ريفو
أصعب مهمته، وكان
الوضع الأكثر رعبًا هو القيادة خلف
مركبة إزالة الألغام بينما كانت
تمرر لنا، ويقول إننا كنا نتعرض
لقصف مستمر، وكانت القذائف
تهبط على بعد أمتار قليلة منا، ولا
تزال القوات الأوكرانية في حالة سيئة.
رئيس البلاد المتفوق فلاديمير
زيلينسكي موجود في الولايات المتحدة ويضغط على
إدارة بايدن للحصول على المزيد من الذخيرة.
تقول نيسلامنا إنها ستقاتل من أجل
مستقبل أطفالها،
أريدهم أن يعيشوا في
بلد مزدهر، كما تقول. قلت مرات عديدة إن
مهمتنا صغيرة نحن  كل ما علينا فعله هو
استعادة حدودنا ولكن سيتعين عليهم
إعادة بناء البلد بأكمله وهذه
مهمة أصعب بكثير،
ويخدم آرون زوجها بالفعل في
نفس اللواء كقائد مدفعي،
وتقول إن هناك أحيانًا
مواقف حيث تقوم بتحديد
الأهداف وتحديدها  ثم أطلق النار عليها ولكن
ما سمعناه منها ومن
الشعوب الأخرى على خط المواجهة الجنوبي
هو أنهم يخبروننا أنهم بحاجة إلى المزيد من
الأسلحة وأنهم بالتأكيد بحاجة إلى المزيد من
الذخيرة، ويقولون إن لديهم
الدافع، ولديهم المهارات ولكن الآن
إنها الأسلحة والذخيرة التي
يحتاجون إليها حقًا للمضي قدمًا،
حسنًا فريد، شكرًا جزيلاً لك من
زاباريسيا الليلة،
شكرًا لك